good morning Hank it's Tuesday so as you
may be aware you are the training kit
sponsor of America's favorite third tier
English football team AFC Wimbledon wait
I feel a camera - side note coming on
side note you may not like sports but
the story I'm about to tell you is not
about sports it's about whether hope is
the correct response to the human
condition okay so at the end of each
season the four worst teams in English
football's third tier are demoted to the
fourth tier being among these places is
known as being in the relegation zone
and you know it is obviously undesirable
you don't want to have a fourth tier
English football team because then you
got to go to places like Milton Keynes
to play your football right so AFC
Wimbledon entered the relegation zone
near the beginning of this season in
October and then they stayed there in
fact for most of the season AFC
Wimbledon has been in last place and
relegation felt inevitable I mean the
truth is even in the third tier a lot of
teams are owned by really rich owners
AFC Wimbledon meanwhile are owned by
their fans each of whom pay about 30
bucks a year to be owners for context
some of the clubs in the third tier have
an annual budget that is more than ten
times larger than our annual budget so
how are we going to compete here's how
bad things were the club got a new
manager and in January brought in a
couple new players including a 21 year
old goalkeeper named Aaron Ramsdale and
then Wimbledon went on this incredible
run winning five out of six games after
which we were still in last place the
effort was Noble but almost guaranteed
to be futile almost guaranteed almost
somehow Wimbledon kept winning in fact
we've only lost one of our last 11 games
that 21 year old goalkeeper turned out
to be a wizard
our defense started clicking we started
scouring the kinds of goals that are the
glory of our past scrappy ugly goals and
then on Saturday after 189 days in the
relegation zone AFC Wimbledon beat
Wickham 2-1 to move into the dizzying
heights of 19th place with one game to
go it still might all fall apart of
course we likely have to win or tie that
last game in order to stay up but we've
got a chance if Wimbledon do stay up
it'll be one of the greatest great
escapes in English football history and
I think I know why it has happened the
players kept playing for each other and
for their community as if the situation
were not hopeless even when it was
that is my favorite thing about humans
we are relentless we don't know when
we're licked even when we should give up
we don't it said everything to me that
when Wimbledon scored a last-second goal
against league-leading Luton Town a
couple weeks ago the players ran
immediately to and in some cases into
the stands it reminded me of 2013 when
Jack Minson scored a penalty in the last
game of that season to keep Wimbledon in
the fourth tier and then celebrated by
borrowing a fans hat now of course I
know that every reprieve is only
temporary to borrow a line from Hank
Williams you'll never get out of this
world alive even if the miracle last
through Saturday it won't last forever
but I don't need forever lately I've
been frustrated by how much effort is
for nothing like over the last few years
I've worked so much on stories that I
eventually had to abandon and that's
painful because you want work that you
put into the world to have been for
something but I think that might be the
wrong way to conceive of effort earlier
in that Luton Town game Aaron Ramsdale
made an absolutely ridiculous save on a
deflected shot most of the time
scrambling to try to tip away that
deflected shot won't mean anything
either you won't get there or you'll
lose the game anyway but you can't know
which time putting in the effort will
work so you put the effort in every time
that's what I learned about writing from
football Hank if you want to support AFC
Wimbledon you can get this awesome scarf
it even says dftba nerdfighteria on it
there's a link in the doobly-doo also if
you're in or around Bradford this
weekend head over to the game and scream
your head off on my behalf god I'm so
nervous
all right Hank I'll see you on Friday